pour les 220 mille français qui
choisissent chaque année la crémation
les cendres sont remises aux familles
mais certains métaux précieux ne brûle
pas les prothèses les dents en or les
stérilet au cuivre par exemple sont
collectées par des entreprises
spécialisées qui les revendent à
d'autres sociétés dans les secteurs de
l'aéronautique de l'automobile ou de
l'électroménager une pratique méconnue
des français parce qu'à une demande qui
a été faite à la famille au moins enfin
j'imagine moi c'est mes parents devait
décéder quand leurs extraits des choses
j'aurais aimé quand même donné mon
consentement quoi et on peut faire des
choses que ça les appartient pas c'est
pas normal
il faut dire à leur famille sinon
c'était sud et voilà le magazine 60
millions de consommateurs a enquêté
une centaine de tonnes de métaux
précieux et récoltés chaque année un
marché de plusieurs millions d'euros 20%
des recettes vont aux sociétés 80% au
crématorium mais rien aux familles des
défunts
il ya un business qui est caché et enfin
de l'argent et encore récolté j'allais
presque dire sur le dos des familles
donc il faut une plus grande
transparence d'un point de vue éthique
et moral pour les familles et il faut
que cet argent serve et soit d'utilité
publique
selon nos informations chaque
crématorium toucherait ainsi en moyenne
vingt mille euros par an un des
représentants des crématoriums public
affirme que cet argent est reversé à des
associations
là je que l'ensemble des crématoriums
public revers fait convenir à des
associations caritatives et ne rentre
pas dans des 20 du chiffre d'affaires
bénéfice quelconque 60 millions de
consommateurs suggère que ces fonds
bénéficie au financement des obsèques
des personnes modestes
[Applaudissements]